how're you doing today sir I'm pretty
good how are you I'm doing excellent
listen let me start by saying congrats
on the season it's so well done I'm
gonna start with the generic thing but
how much did you know about narcos prior
to getting involved the series yeah I've
been a fan since the first season yeah
so as a fan what surprised you about the
making of the show that maybe you
weren't expecting I don't know that I
was really surprised about anything
because what I'll say is I I was I was
very grateful to take an experience of
shooting in another country that's kind
of like the motherland of my culture I
grew up in Wyoming but my dad's from
Mexico so I have I have Mexican blood
Mexican heritage in my soul but I didn't
really grow up with the Mexican culture
necessarily in my household right so go
into Mexico and experiencing Mexico and
the culture and his people and kind of
being a part of society and seeing what
it's about and learning Spanish properly
it was really truly special for me what
is it what is the shooting schedule like
when you're making a show like this a
lot of TV shows are like eight days
shoots is it like that what is it like
we I think we would do five five on two
offs I think we take weekends off but it
was because there's so many storylines
the it was very inconsistent we you know
some days would be super long day some
days would be you know ten twelve hour
days but and it it was it wasn't obscene
it wasn't up seen it by any means every
but there was - there was two units
going on at all times making sure that
we got everything because it's really
you're shooting ten movies it's ten
episodes is there ten movies and we shot
it in eight months you know throughout
from November of last year until June so
it's a lot it takes a lot of work
especially make a show look like narcos
looks and and feels and the acting it's
like it you need to you need to take
your time well one of the reasons why
the show I think is is so popular around
the world is because you take so much
time to film
because it looks so good in the
production design and the costumes you
feel like you've been transported yeah
yeah we feel like that too and if we
were and we're in costume and we're
driving old crappy cars and barely run
and because they're from the 80s or 70s
or whatever we can get our hands on we
are transported there so it does feel
feels very natural and it feels very
honest to be a part of that world
you got to do a lot of cool [ __ ] yeah
did you have like a day or two would you
was there a certain episode or a certain
scene that you're reading in the
scripture like oh my god I cannot wait
to do this well what was cool well I'll
preface that is that we went early we
went about a week early so that the the
mic room the cops I called him showed us
which is Mexican for cops right Spanish
we went and did tactical training so we
did a day of tactical training using
learning how to use the weapons the
style that they used in the 80s right
there's a different stance and now that
they did in the 80s so we had to learn
all that stuff we learned how to walk
around buildings and walls how they did
in the 80s so that was very interesting
and that was very cool was another party
a question what sequence oh there's a
ton of really really great action
sequences and and not even the action
sequences there's really big scenes that
were in the safe houses with with our
crew trying to figure out what we're
gonna do next the funnest part for me
was knowing that every one of us were
out to help each other and make sure
that this the best scene as possible
there was no there was no egos we just
wanted everything to work and ever want
to look good what is it do you haven't
seen the season yet no I was seen I was
gonna ask you about deleted scenes and
stuff but let's switch it something else
what do you think it is like people love
the show and they love learning about
like what goes on behind the scenes in
drug culture and and but you know all
this stuff what do you think it is that
makes this kind of genre so popular ah
part of its drama in remain the
there is an allure to it that there's a
part I think that there's a part and a
psyche of every one of us that would
like to be able to do whatever we want
to do when we want to do it right and it
doesn't make it right it's just a
different it's just just different life
there's there are rules that we have to
follow by and some people don't follow
those rules at the end of the day it's
like everyone needs to be able to put
food in our mouth and have a roof over
our head and make sure the families are
taken care of I forgot your question
again
what I was going to say what what is it
about like the genre that makes it it's
so calm well I think it narcos Mexico
specific it's I think it's because it's
a nation super in the United States it's
our neighbor and while Columbia the
version of Columbia the first three
seasons were very popular as well I
think Mexico really kind of like relates
to us because it's right here and we've
heard about these things throughout the
years you know I mean we've heard the
names we've heard we know about the drug
culture we know about all these things
so kind of feels very familiar and to
kind of get a little bit of an insight
on where it all started because there's
a lot of historical stuff goes on here
there's a lot of embellishing just to
kind of keep the story moving and keep
it entertaining but there are you know
some things that we go oh I remember
that time I have family members ago all
right remember that remember that you
know I was young I was you know in the
80s it was I was just a kid but being
able to kind of use somewhat of a
historic base to make a fictional show
and entertaining is kind of a cool thing
it's not a documentary so it's you know
it's you have to take it with a little
bit of grain of salt do your own
research and you know a hundred percent
you know what no one thinks we're
watching a documentary oh yeah yeah but
some people take it that way you know I
mean like they're they're taking they're
saying that this is this is a it's all
of its real some of its factual but some
of us like very much heightened 100% but
like there's stuff in when what the show
does is it mixes in history with the
embellishing but like when they show a
photo or they recreate a certain
sequence yeah that really happened yeah
you know you you know you'd play anyway
yeah when you think back on the show you
obviously did some cool sequences we
was the trickiest one you think to pull
off I mean there's there's a - what can
I say I'll say there's a there is a
there's a big sequence that was kind of
tricky only because of the weather the
the weather in Mexico can be
unpredictable so there was there was
about a week of getting rained out and
having scheduled pushed and like really
really big sequences so the weather did
that was that that was the most
challenging part about doing this
because our crew was incredible the the
special effects the stunt guys everyone
from everyone from at all the
departments they were they were so good
and so prepared it was just the weather
that was that would hold us back
honestly it was you're not gonna throw
someone under the bus it's basically the
weather
no no really it was like there's
brainstorms and monsoons we we did a
shoot we did one of our locations is in
I don't think I'm gonna get in trouble
for this as in a desert I'll say it's in
the desert sand mozzarella and a week
later it was like a torrential downpour
and the city got massively flooded
massive massively we were just there and
like sharing pictures on histograms like
yo did you see this
it's like we were literally just there
like we were staying in the hotel like
work waters rushing buying cars are
going by the building was I saying
that's crazy yeah on that note I have to
stop I'm just gonna say congrats on the
season and being a part of it thank you
hope you have a fantastic day Thank You
likewise